ces deux écossais de the a qui sont dans
le back up sont comme ça tient à un
moment il y en a qui regarde l'autre le
voit et aériens de mimétisme alors ses
2,06 de ce nom qu'ils sachent rien à
voir l'image
ils sont dans le back up sont comme ça
il y en a qui regarde l'autre comme ça
il fait 1
je n'ai pas vu tes n'a pas l'air bien tu
as des tas des poils thé des vers l'eau
tu dis mais c'est peut-être parce que je
suis inquiet oui abrutis lolo s'achever
est vaste et vague d'eau propre prandi
j'aurai un menu enfants la femme v8
ricotta effet non juste l'enfant
les points à l'époque et plaçant marie
bigard qui vit à montpellier
[Applaudissements]
cette famille s'est passé a été propre
c'est un homme et rentre dans une
parfumerie dit à la vendeuse c'est
bientôt la saint valentin je vraiment
offrir un très bon parfum ma femme et
j'y connais rien du tout puis elles
changent souvent donc vous allez vous
conseiller et la demoiselle très très
joli
donc elle lui et elle commence à lui
faire sentir des trucs effet mais vous
vous avez un super parfum vous sentez
très très beau oui mais le problème avec
ça c'est qu'après tous les pervers
volant mercier
ah oui non mais il faut aller trop
propre
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
tu ne finis pas maire et le curé revenus
king burgert ya une île très pratique et
très court rappelons ici c'est incurable
non pas du tout
comment dit-on témoins de jéhovah en
chinois ding dong
bouder c'est la première fois que sa vie
qui vient à paris on a compris
maintenant ils arrivent à gare du nord
il appelle un taxi prend le taxi il
rentre dans le taxi taxi je vous dépose
ou montparnasse niva et pendant tout le
trajet hills ou le taxi avec des
questions et la tour eiffel c'est
comment et les filles comment elles sont
aidées par isaïe le plus d'accidents peu
plus loin mais le calcule pas trop à un
moment donné et gionta qui excusez moi
le petit roux gravé au bout de la
voiture c'est quoi mais qu'elle avait
une mercedes ils voient que ça ait dit
ça c'est un viseur rien mais qui
m'énerve dans la rue je visite les
classes et dit regarde par exemple cette
vieille dame
il faut aussi faut se mettre en taxi il
faut aussi une femme arrive à la vieille
dame itunes ils entendent pas elle met
des à jaws moi j'ai ouvert la porte ils
auraient raté
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
très fort le beau temps arrive la bonne
soeur lee dans un taxi c'est une très
belle ville mais par direct assuré le
show côté xi et regarde dans le rétro il
arrive pas dévisser son regard de ses
deux soeurs qui est d'une beauté
incroyable
et comme certains avaient ressorti lundi
que ce qui se passe où vous vous
regardez plus dans le rétro que que
devant vous va avoir un accident et dit
non c'est pas ça mais tu veux c'est
tellement belle t mon mon fantasme à moi
ce serait un jour d'embrasser une bonne
soeur aussi belle que vous me servent à
des écoutes et il n'y a pas de problème
si vous êtes croyant une part est
célibataire mais dit je suis croyant je
suis croyant je suis célibataire
niall du bon garez-vous sur le côté hier
su côté le type est derrière et lui
roule une gamelle mais d'en faire mais
non ça va après jamais relâcher bras
c'est tout lui passe la langue sur les
yeux dans les trous de nez par des
gamins incroyable heroes monde à bayeux
et mis cinq minutes après il se met à
pleurer tout en conduisant est là il
sanglote ça dit mais qu'est ce qui vous
arrive et dit je sanglote parce que je
suis un gros menteur je suis pas croyant
et je suis marié je suis marié service
est pas grave moi je m'appelle raymond
je vous tiens nouvelle
[Applaudissements]